to where the black rook and white will  make a new queen and hans you can tell  on his body language he's almost ready  to throw in the towel and resign  but just a couple of last moves uh  why not just show the audience show us  why the position is lost  but no more tricks unfortunately for him  and uh there we go two pawns they were  on the sixth rank they've moved up  they've graduated to the seventh rank  and now the black knight attacking the  white rook so be careful but you can  flick in a check gain a bit of time and  i think we're about to have it there we  go magnus takes the win about to make a  new queen  and he's ready for the semi-final magnus  carlsen will play another semi-final  match in the meltdown champions chester  after three games knocking out the  american teenager hans niemann